oui devant une intention qu'il faut
souligner qu est celle de réconcilier
les français avec l'europe ce qui est
une belle ambition et qui suppose
d'ailleurs que l'europe aussi
participent à cette réconciliation
et puis pour le reste on a un discours
assez dense mais qui va demander à être
déclinée préciser parce que au fil de
l'intervention j'ai entendu 20 à 30
milliards d'euros de dépenses nouvelles
augmentations de diverses prestations
sociales allongement du congé de
maternité de voile a pas mal de dépenses
nouvelles
j'ai entendu 20 à 30 milliards de procès
dans - également de graisse très manga
thouars en particulier le regardant
maintient la baise avec la suppression
taxe d'habitation et la baisse de la
moyenne des 3 importune et puis j'ai
entendu aussi des engagements très
fermes sur la lutte contre les déficits
tout ça me paraît devoir être un peu
précises et pour que l'on comprenne bien
comment on peut faire des dépenses
nouvelles en faire moins de recettes
tenir la baisse contre un déficit si ce
n'est à peut-être abandonné j'ai eu une
petite alerte et ça aussi ça demandera
être explicité sur la fait que l'état
pourrait se séparer d'activités qu'ils
assument aujourd'hui quand je pense pas
qu'il s'agisse d'activités industrielles
puisque déjà l'état l'a beaucoup moins
qu'avant
et qu'est ce que le gouvernement entend
privatiser dans les activités de l'état
voilà donc monsieur mes interrogations à
l'issue de ce discours